enfin mireille mireille à paris va bien
un vrai changement
mireille oui
[Musique]
j'étais dans ce genre première l
officier sur notre cher brice et est
allée tout ce qui s'appelle aussi titre
avait bien sûr moyen toujours que mon
modèle
[Rires]
[Musique]
kelly la perruque là je croise à nouveau
style à maxime unité c'est mon style
tous les jours sur le nouveau parfum est
d'essayer de passer les étapes franchies
dans le miroir aller de l'autre côté du
miroir
et voilà que ça donne
voilà je suis filmé encore toi tu vois
[Musique]
ça n'a pas raté
ça promet rien fait même la dernière
fois qu'elle est super bien
[Musique]
je pense que j'ai un dossier sur toi
aujourd'hui je vais te pointes la vie
bêta commence à 10 ans espagnoles
m
pourquoi
[Musique]
de retour sous ventilation l'instant du
magnifique nouveau titre encore j'ai vu
ma wii alors dis-moi oui tu chantes
aurez vous regarde est-ce que tu connais
tel suis parmi vous avez comme elle est
belle car ce n'est pas vivre à 100 et
cac derrière derrière elle un costume
permet aux olympiens
[Musique]